it's interesting
that i and i've noticed this in
relationships post-divorce
is that
they will tell you
at some point
what they're going to do before they do
it and in my case my ex did exactly that
it was probably several years before the
divorce
and she kept on egging me on to go down
to
this next town santa barbara where it's
just gorgeous and it costs
you know buy-in is 10 million bucks or
something for these beautiful houses
overlooking the ocean what do you mean
going down you mean like selling a place
you guys ran to move down there just go
start looking yeah you know she's
hitting that wanting to go down there
well that was beyond my pay grade
and i knew
i i grew up in california i know exactly
what that place was and she was all
excited about it i was like hey man we
already live in a multi-million dollar
house and we had we did just fine
now she was very excited about this and
was going from like a seven figure home
to an eight-figure home
well okay
like a 13 million dollar home sort of
thing yeah yeah going from a three
million dollar house to a 13. yeah yeah
okay
something like that yeah you could you
could go all over the uh
but that's kind of the area
and so
um
i knew what it was like down there and i
kind of just blew it off and then i
didn't think about it much anymore well
today she shacked up with some dude he's
got a lot of money
and um
she buried him and they have their she
has her beautiful house over looking to
see
and
i don't want to kiss and tell too much
but i heard it through the grapevine
that
um she had to compromise a lot of stuff
in order to get that
and i haven't spoken to her
but the bottom line is i was really
happy
when i heard this because
i was like
well that's exactly what she wanted it
wasn't like
i did anything horrible or wrong or you
know it's just it's the ultimate in
hypergamy right you know it's it's just
that to the nth degree
and
all right so but you start questioning
yourself a lot when that happens when
because when i was going through it
because that didn't happen for five or
six years after
it wasn't like she had this relationship
waiting and i didn't have one waiting
either
so
but then when i looked back at it i said
yeah that's right she said that
she said that's what she was going to do
she actually told me and then i look at
other relationships i've had since
and when i really
you know i've been single now for 10
years or maybe nine
and i've had a handful of relationships
some for six months some for a couple
years
and when you know you always get into
something and you go
oh well i you think this and you you
hear what they say but you just ignore
the parts that you don't want to hear
and but but then when it ends and you go
oh yeah they said that in the beginning
they really meant it
so
that's what happened with her so she
always she already knew so i would warn
people and they're in the same situation
to be very aware because maybe
you can deal with it somehow i don't
know
don't pay attention to
red flags like you could literally grab
a red flag and wave it like this it's
like yo here's a red flag and they'll be
like
she's got great boobs and you know she's
you know it's pretty it smells nice and
they don't they don't do anything else
right or in my case you just you know
you're rolling along and you're
comfortable there's really not much i
could have done about it honestly
without leveraging like hell which
i kind of did that anyway and and you
leverage your leverage and then if it
works out great then maybe you could buy
the next thing they want you know maybe
it's a better car or maybe it's a better
house or maybe it's better for whatever
it is that they want they want something
right how old were the kids when you
guys split up okay so when we split my
youngest he was 14 and then my middle
one was 16 and my oldest was 18.
and the 18 and the funny thing was i had
the best relationship ever with my
middle
daughter up until that point i mean she
was just daddy's girl and we'd do
everything together i'd fly her around
to her
she was
she was an aspiring actress and she
could sing and so
she'd go for commercial
auditions in la and so i'd fly her down
there would spend the day together
she would
confide in me
things that little girls would you know
i was like oh my friends are weird and
how come my boys never kissed me and
what should i say to a guy if he says
this and things that a girl would ask
her dad and i i was flattered you know
i'd laugh with her and get a hamburger
and a shake
and um
and we had that and and it was nice
the day the divorce was announced
she never talked to me again ever again
well it took
uh
about five years
so so why did she stop talking to you
the day of the divorce
she wouldn't say she still to this day
hasn't said but i but i i i
i my my actually um
i don't say too much because there's
some privacy but but uh
there was some help elsewhere to kind of
close that gap
and
um she's
what's happened is now we talk
regularly and she's well into her career
she's got a big job in washington dc of
all things and and
she's doing some really great things and
she's proud of herself and i'm proud of
her and we did get together for for
dinner and so slowly it's mending
but to broach that subject you know
hardcore
it's like
i you have to you know it's like any
relationship you know you don't want to
just blast it open and say why did you
do this did you ask her siblings to see
what they thought of it
yeah
her brother and and he doesn't he
doesn't want to get in the middle
and you know my son
he never stopped talking to me
all from the very beginning
but
my ex was very very clever in keeping us
separated
so i think i said this last time did you
play little games like
oh he has a baseball game on thursday so
i would show up on thursday well turned
out the game was on wednesday
and
okay
so giving you the complete wrong date so
you show up like a pleb yeah you know so
those kinds of things constantly of just
being harassed by misinformation
and then you look like an ass you know
and
and so i picked up on that he's playing
the game like looking in the stands
going where's dad right and you're not
sure you know and then she knows i'm
coming down and now i've got that one
down where okay i'm not going to be
there the wrong day well
you know of course it's why wouldn't i
go i've driven the long way why wouldn't
i want to have dinner with him well of
course she has dates set up for him oh
no no he only has 10 minutes and even if
i ask it's and there's some massive
thing she is the master of
of control
and
he
you know didn't want to get
he's got two sisters and a mom to deal
with at home and
he doesn't want to make his life
uncomfortable what about the other um
girl did she the oldest one you guys
when you split up
was told
okay so it's this is all the
disinformation stuff that's going on you
know it's like
my ex this by the way guys is called
parental alienation and family law it's
where one parent tries to put distance
between the other parent by making up
a false narrative that would encourage
the child not to want to have a
relationship with that parent sorry go
ahead
right so
it's and i knew this during the court
battle that this was going on and i knew
my remedies were to okay to to fight
this parental alienation you're gonna
have to do psychology you know
psychological analysis on that on her
then she would require one of me and
then we'd have to do it to the kids and
then you know back and forth and you're
gonna spend
probably 50 60 000 going through this
crap
and the the eighteen-year-old was out of
the picture because she's eighteen and
the judge said okay well mom can take
care of the kids but dad you can have
i'm gonna leave it up to the kids they
wanna see you
so they were i wasn't
i wasn't told
i couldn't see them but and they weren't
told they couldn't see me but the judges
said they're 14 and 16. i'm going to let
them make their own decision
and um
so but but the things that were going on
which i knew where i assumed a lot of
times by her because the kids didn't
even want to say because i knew she was
masterful at this
i would have to go back and prove it and
and they would just cause such a
a
discourse
in the um
in their lives i didn't want to rattle
their lives that much and i knew sooner
or later they'd come back my sons turned
out great my daughters turned out great
too
and i will give one you know she got all
of my money but to her benefit she spent
it on the kids the way i would have have
wanted them to
wanted her to
so
she made sure they got through schools
she made sure they you know got
opportunities in their lives to to get
to the next step etc my son started a
business and
and so on
so
but
i i was
thinking about this today in fact is
like how do you stop that from happening
the next generation again you know an
extreme amount of education is what it's
going to take and i don't
i don't think they're aware of it yet
until they get older
but this is exactly what my ex-wife did
at that time is she blew apart our
uh
relationship
at exactly the time
her parents split when she was that age
and her siblings were the same age as
all three of my kids he was one of three
and so it's like you recreate this
nightmare in your head and you think
it's going to happen again and then you
end up creating it hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you